Good, I hear some interesting discussions already as I come into the room.
From these discussions, I gather that you are trying out local models.
Yes, we're trying our best to not have to pay for something online.
You'll see where this goes, I think, I fear.
But yeah, I'm curious to hear your experiences.
You've tried things, so maybe not all of us have tried these things, so maybe some of
you can give an introduction to what you tried.
I can, because mine was the worst experience, but it was also the first, so we can build
up on top of that, because what I did is I installed Olama just on a CPU, 8 gigabytes of RAM, and
then I tried to run Gemma 4.
Okay, how many parameters is that?
The smallest one, it has like, oh, they do some magic where they have effective parameters.
I think you should say first, Gemma 4 comes in four different variants.
2 billion, 4 billion, 26 billion, and 31 billion.
And the 26 billion has only 4 billion active and the others passive, whatever that means.
But the same for the E2B, because that's also like the effective 2 billion,
that's why it says that what's the E?
But that doesn't have passive parameters.
It doesn't, but they do some magic where they hide some layers, I don't know.
Yeah.
Because also there, 2 billion parameters are way larger than the Quen models, for example.
And that's why those didn't run on my PC at all.
I don't have enough RAM.
Then we started to run it on Otis computer.
You have 16 gigabytes of VRAM, so we managed, supposedly, what?
I mean, it's sort of fake because it's an integrated GPU and it can share the RAM with
the CPU and it can share up to 60 megabytes.
So 16 gigabyte models fit.
And then I chose, technically, the Gemma 431D should also fit in some quantizations, possibly.
The annoying thing is that it takes some experimentation to make these models work on the laptop, because
first of all, you need RAM reserved for your operating system and to run the graphical environment.
So you can't just put all of your, you can't just put the model in the complete GPU VRAM,
and because then nothing works.
So you have to manually experiment how many layers of the model you want to load off to the GPU.
And that's, it's not trivial, I guess.
But I made it work with the 26 gigabyte model, the 26 billion parameter model, which is 15.6 gigabytes required.
It just fits, but I can't put the whole model in, into the GPU because then everything crashes.
So I still have to select some layers.
And then it runs at about 16 to 13 tokens per second.
That's very good.
Which is okay.
I just tried converting one of Henrik's exercise sheets into types.
And it worked with minor corrections.
And it didn't understand exactly how types work.
But it put, I now have a PDF of the exercise sheets again, which is not completely ugly.
So that was sort of, is that the final types version?
Yes, that is the types version.
I mean, you can show it around, looks like this.
Okay.
It's okay.
Yeah.
And it didn't take too long.
It took about four minutes, almost five minutes.
Interesting.
Which is for a local model, better than I've seen before.
And how long would it take you to type the same document?
Probably more than five minutes.
Okay.
Maybe not much more.
Yes.
Maybe about 15 minutes.
Yeah.
I presume.
And I have to do corrections.
Yeah.
But because it doesn't get everything right.
But it's also not an agent.
If it was an agent, then maybe it could have corrected itself.
And I'm just trying to get the image recognition to work.
Because that was just from the text of the PDF.
I saw it.
So only had the text as context, not the images.
So I didn't exactly know how the old document layout looked.
And for some reason, I can't put images into the input prompt right now.
So I'll see how to fix that.
Interesting.
What I would suggest in that particular instance is that you
use a...
If you want to convert images to LaTeX, there is a model.
It's not an LLM.
It's a...
My screen is that again.
Okay.
I'll fix that in a second.
I will recommend a OCR technology neural network.
I think it's developed by Facebook.
It's called the Marker.
Oh, I've tried that before.
Yeah.
It was very slow.
It's very slow, but there are various models you can use.
You don't have to use the stock one.
So I use Marker all the time now because I don't want to use an LLM to do image to text
when a more specialized model works.
And so I have a GPU.
So it's...
But no, I've actually been using Marker on CPU as well occasionally.
And if you hand it a PDF as a scan, it can convert it to LaTeX, not types, but you know,
maybe as an intermediate step.
So this works extremely, extremely well and recognizes equations.
So what I've done is I have a workflow now where, for example, I might have a transcript
from a conversation.
We may have some handwritten notes and we send those through specialized models.
We don't send them through LLMs.
I send them through a local model, Whisper to do the transcripts, Marker to do the notes.
It gets a first-class LaTeX.
I don't use times.
So it converts handwritten notes.
It converts handwritten notes as well into Markdown, basically.
That's what Marker does.
And Markdown with LaTeX in line.
So it's the worst of every whatever.
I mean, but you've got something, right?
And then from this something, you've got a text of the discussion
and a first pass at the text and equations.
And then you can ask a local model then to combine these sources
and create a best types or best LaTeX or whatever version.
And that way, you focus the compute where you can, right?
So the idea here is that you use Marker to do the Marker job,
Whisper to do the Whisper job, LLM to do the natural language job.
And so it's pretty tricky on laptops.
You're all running into this, this kind of like hard barrier
that you're about one generation of technology behind.
What we'd all ideally ideal scenario is I believe
to order some and you have Apple devices where you can probably run local models
pretty well because of the shared memory.
Is that right?
But I did not try it.
You did not try it yet.
How much RAM do you have in your laptops?
5 to 16.
16.
Oh, it's a lot of the status.
Ah, okay, yeah.
The ideal hardware to have, which we don't have
because it's impossible to buy anymore, is 32 gigabytes Apple laptops.
All the models are just optimized for this.
So you can run them real fast on that hardware.
But hey, we can do what we got to do.
We do what we can do and then as we say, we're setting it up.
It's just such a painful progress for this server down in the basement,
but it is happening.
But what we will have soon is a decent graphics card 3090 in a desktop here.
So that'll be an intermediate level.
And that runs Marker, Whisper, local models like Quinn.
Pretty happily there's no agentic models.
So within a couple of weeks maybe we'll have that ready for you
and then you can experiment on better hardware.
But I think it's actually very good to really painfully experience it the way I did.
So that when you transition to other models, you can use all these tricks you develop
in order to get the most out of the crappy models.
Okay, so is this kind of the end of the experience?
I mean, it's doing useful work for you though in one sense, right?
I've yet to try longer conversations.
Of course, the context window isn't maxed out
and I haven't tried many things yet, but it works and it doesn't just spit out trash like
those first model and like Quinn 3.5, which was this nonsense.
So Quinn 3.5, it just didn't...
It just circled around and around and didn't output anything usable.
And did you Google that as a problem? Like do people complain about this?
I probably don't have enough context size.
That's my suspicion because whenever it starts reasoning, it kind of loops.
It gets caught in, it's overthinking.
Yeah, it's overthinking, it gets caught in a loop and it reiterates on stuff that it already decided on.
It's funny, this conversation, I've had it like three or four times
with completely different groups of people that their local models are overthinking
and I haven't looked into this for a while, so I'll have to look into this.
Because I didn't have the chain of thought tokens when I experimented with local models.
It's a kind of new thing. I mean, you can turn thinking off.
Yeah, when I do that, it kind of does the job, but for me, it doesn't do anything useful at all.
It's just a happy thing to play around with.
It's a happy thing to play around with.
So I tried the intermediate model, 4 billion. First, I tried if it can recitate Harry Potter,
because in larger models, this is just in the weights, but the smaller one wasn't able to.
So it refused when I said, give me page something of Harry Potter,
cause a copyright, and I became able to speed talk it into doing it. But when I gave it the first few
sentences, I tried something, but it was completely off. So the smaller models don't contain culture,
apparently. And also, I tried some more technical stuff. It was able to define me a Hilbert's base
in the C-star algebra, but it wasn't able to prove me that a state that states on a sub-algebra extend
to states on the whole algebra. It wasn't able to do that or even state that that's correct.
Okay. Yeah.
Any other experiences?
Any other experiences, I tried to load it into Python with the Transformers
library, also the same model I believe for E4B. Yeah, it works. I find that interesting too.
So like it's a bit more raw and I'm not yet to reach the chat mode. I can
send one input and then it gives me the output. And what I tried is to get it to write me some kind of
web search tool prompt or something and it refused that and it refused to believe that it was
running in python it always said no i'm in the cloud but maybe you have another one
and but then when i used an admin prompt it worked okay so like you have this low user
prompt and this low admin prompt and so you didn't believe the user but it believes the
admin that's very interesting i didn't know about that actually yeah i'm not sure if it's actually
called yeah but this is a thing we write down we learned that this happens and then maybe it's
useful in the future yeah interesting interesting um so i'm very i think you know one of the core
goals is that you experiment with these things uh and then the second and then learn stuff and share
this learning right you know a little little comment about admin prompts or might be useful for us
later on you know a comment about this works that doesn't work this can be all useful as as the
seminar progresses oh i've got something to share yes you said that uh language models as an output
they generate json yes right yes because uh and i've tried that i set up an api where like locally call
my own api yeah and then it does return those exact json strings yes as an answer but i found them very
confusing to read yes because they like the keys they use are different for every message that i send
so i wanted to ask you if you maybe know how how this actually works in practice because uh now we get
into this this is scaffolding discussion so it's what happens around the output of an llm um all i can say
is you can make it pretty by using jq this command it makes it slightly more readable the output uh more
i don't really know about the outputs of these models okay yeah but maybe you do yeah actually i was a bit
uh confused because it didn't output in json for me maybe it's a library that affected the way but
is your question it has some some tokens yeah it has a tool token or it has a role token and so on
but i maybe i'm not i'm not sure if i am below the json lawyer or above i think you might be below it
right okay i think you're really you're really putting numbers through matrices yeah yeah and so the api
which is different from the llm right the llm is this function is a mathematical function
yes and that just emits tokens and there's no jasons coming out of that it's just
strings of stuff oh it's not it can emit json it just doesn't yeah but then that's just json
represented as tokens that's right yeah it's not really json the model doesn't really know about json
what it does is it emits tokens and there's a textual representation of those tokens and that's
always when you see these angular brackets with type characters and then there's it says like tool
or something or prompt yeah and then you can what your api does or what chat gpt the interface does or
llama or olama they just transform that representation of tokens into a json exactly object because you can
send it over the network and read it with every programming language so but there's no the model
doesn't know about json no because i understood you in a way that screen the actual screen oh okay sorry
yeah that was unclear yeah by the llm that that's the json yeah depending on your harness it is it's like
how do you wrap this where do you cut the function and say what's the output and what's the harness
so at the level you're doing it with a transformers library
you're really evaluating a mathematical function outcomes tokens and then the python around it
already starts to wrap these tokens in this json and so what's the function and where's that not
the function so there's this kind of gray area around the transformer which is the thing that's really just
emitting tokens and that the stuff you get from the api which is json wrapped but yeah you have yeah i was
wondering is there some kind of standard how to translate these tones into json um not that i'm
aware of but there's probably i mean there must be uh is a quicker answer if you ask your model
it might know um there must be a python library that is doing it somewhere like in the transformers
library yeah so it's more like do all models have the same token standard and the same mostly i mean
it's a wild west so people are creating models that don't obey any rules um and people you know create
models where they have standards so that everyone can talk to each other i you know you know about
this place right yeah i don't know if i mentioned that in any previous seminars but if you want to
download a model this is the place to find it so what we're in is the pre-bootstrap phase of your
of your learning so what do i mean by that you're having to do everything manually you're having to
kind of coax these things onto your system and then you spend lots of typing time to get them to work
and then they do kind of work and then and then they're not useful and you can't pipe them into other
things where you want to get to is the point and i don't know if you i just don't know if local
models can get you to this point but we want to get to this point where the model itself helps you
do this work so instead of you having to write python in using the transformers library you just say
to an agent write me a python that will get this model running locally and then it the agent goes
off does that for you and now you have it running locally you know freeing yourself from this stuff
that you're having to do at the moment that's coming but it will need that we can give you access to
better agents right at the moment the agents you can get on for absolutely zero pennies as you've
experienced not super great um so the homework that wasn't the homework but it's very interesting
and i'm happy to hear every week about these discoveries uh but the homework was to read one essay
did you read it it's one page
i forgot but maybe someone here can summarize it their experience with reading it and what they
think about it yep i mean okay so the the core idea so the essay was called the bitter lesson i believe
yes yeah the bitter lesson and what is the bitter lesson it's the fact that um we as humans when we try
to build a computer that's specifically tasked to do one thing for example building a chess robot that
we as humans are not that good at like hard implementing the steps we need to that we need
to computer to solve in order to play chess because what we assume is whenever we build a computer is
that or we build an algorithm is that like we as human we can teach it to like think the way a human
would think so we hard code like oh if there's a rook there then take it or whatever but instead like
the most effective thing we can do as researchers building a robot is to just like throw computational
power at it let it learn by itself and just use like this deep learning or the way i don't know how
it was called there but like just using uh a neural network to to to learn how to play chess itself
instead of us trying to teach it because that's that's like the the most intuitive step for us
would be to like oh we need a robot to solve this problem well we teach the robot how to solve this
problem if it's if it's chess or what else was in the text they also had like speech recognition
computer vision and so on and so forth so the best thing you can do for example for computer vision is
to not teach the the computer how to recognize patterns or anything because that's the initial
approach by us humans was to like teach it how to to discover edges and shapes and whatever but no
instead the best we can do is just like let the computer learn by itself use the neural network just
throw computational power at it and the computer kind of teaches itself how to to solve that problem
yep i i think that's more or less my take-home message from it as well does anyone add anything
to that story um uh it was anyone are you happy with this no yeah you shouldn't be happy with this
right what's there's something very wrong with this right we're kind of building black boxes where we
don't know how they work yep i would love for chess computer to at least know there is a person who
understands how it works but the way it is right now it's like no one knows how they work it's a black
box yes exactly that so they do the task but you don't know how or why or both of how and why uh
it's a pretty powerful essay for someone like myself because i followed this stuff since the year 2000 or
so and you know i've really seen the whole research field do this make this mistake over and over and
over and over again like it's not just it does it once the whole research field makes this mistake
every single time um and that is you you have some new computational power and the first thing you
think of doing is oh we as humans know how to solve this problem let's teach it that let's hard code that
in as you said and then it'll be better as a consequence and the thing we don't want to do is just
throw more compute at the problem uh without understanding and somehow this second strategy always wins
and i've seen it happen i haven't seen it happen once or twice i mean i've had to see it happen tens
and twenty times right you know uh so it's a powerful thing to have just witnessed over the years that
this seems to just be true um i don't know if that'll continue to be true but it seems to be
experimentally true that if you have a complicated problem throw compute at it not understanding
and that's something that we're going to have to tackle in in this seminar because i think the
the interesting direction here is to do research with computing power uh and sutton's better lesson
tells us what it tells us that our understanding of science itself if we extrapolate is probably not
useful rather through compute at it and let the computer work out how to do scientific research
that's a bit more out there as a prediction but we we gotta understand this you gotta you gotta accept
this is the way these things work but it'll take some time okay that was the homework uh and today i
wanna i think the last thing that i can tell you before i don't know anything more is about verifiability
so the most important thing with an untrusted source of information is that you can verify so the you know
i told you in the first seminar and we've spoken about the second and you've seen it yourself
you cannot trust the output of these things they will tell you about states and algebras and then they
will claim that you can't extend a subalgebra state on a subalgebra or whatever right they they
have useful knowledge in there but they also have wrong information in there and the
more but what do they offer so they offer high frequency of output so they can continually output
stuff all day long uh but it's not trusted so is this a useful resource or not that's the question
that we shouldn't think about is it a useful resource to have something do things for you
in an automated fashion where there's a probability of error and i would claim the answer is yes it's and
there's a very easy way to to exploit or improve the quality of the output and that is with verifiability
so if you have a string of information where there's some rate of error what you should do
is code against the error you can turn a noisy channel into a perfect channel by using encryption
encryption but not in the sense of like spy codes but in the sense of you're coding against errors it's
an information theory problem what we want to do is we want to minimize these errors by exploiting
repetition that's the best form of communication over a noisy channel so if you're in a noisy channel
you know there's some rate of error what should you send the message three times and take a majority vote
all of a sudden you've reduced the error by a factor of three and so you if you've got infinite compute
thanks to richard sutton uh what should we do well ideally we should ask a thousand llms the same
question and take a majority vote that's the ideal way of doing this uh you know why not a million llms
ask them take a majority vote uh if you know that there that there is a probability of generating the
correct answer already majority votes will reduce the error of bad faulty outputs it sounds obscene but
it's maybe not that obscene we're going to do very soon i think claire at least was volunteering to look
into the cost of using an llm you can already see the cost of inference on your laptop so your battery
goes down at a certain rate you can work out how much money that cost you
uh and if you can sample a million llms for a reasonable cost and get an incredibly high quality
answer the zero cost to you then why not right so that's one thing i wanted to just to stress is the
cost of of of repetition versus the cost of correction versus the cost of the actual cost
so i want to talk today about verification how do we verify stuff from llms that's that's the question
for today and i'm going to show you how uh three or four levels of verification i've already told you
one just repetition like literally repetition can get you higher quality answers uh ask chat gpt ask
claude ask gemini and then take a majority vote of the three three answers it's already better it's
actually it's still possibly wrong but it's probably less wrong and you can get them to check each other's
work and so uh that also increases the probability of of a correct answer so simple uh consensus is the
first way to gain um uh confidence in an unverified source of information so let's talk about consensus
for a bit that's the lowest level so when you publish a paper do you trust it in a scientific journal
i'm going to start with that do you if you read a scientific paper you're trusting what you're
reading why do you trust it because we assume it's reviewed okay how does the review process work
i'm not sure if i should explain this but uh but it's even your idea of the reviewer process my idea is
that uh the journal sends it to some other people who stay anonymous yes and they look at it and uh
they determine whether the scientific methods have been are correct or if there are biases or
any grave errors in these in these publications it's about right um you send a paper after publication
the journal editor decides they're going to at least send it for review they send it to some anonymous
reviewers who read it for correctness and maybe novelty often novelty is a criteria and then uh depending
on the journal there may be one two or three reviewers that sell them more very rare that you'd
have more than three reviewers for a paper and the reviewers write their report send it to the editor
and then the editor makes a decision based on the report whether to accept or review revise or reject
and so when you have a paper in a journal what what's how much level of confidence is there in
that right you know how much information has been truly verified it depends i think is the correct
answer it depends on what the reviewers did do you know how long the average referee report is
if you're lucky it's about a page so if you send in a 30 page paper to a journal and you get the
review i don't know you guys contradict me here but i'm not sure i've ever seen a referee report
longer than a page or two well i once saw a three or four page i've not submitted it i mean i think
math journals are quite they're pretty pretty hard yeah they're pretty hard but in physics sometimes
paragraph two you're lucky if you get a page yeah so you've submitted a 30 page paper
and you get half a page at best maybe a page of commentary back from the reviewer who's a human
or was a human at least um and uh it makes some statement about the correctness of the paper but
is that enough like does that mean that the paper is correct most of the times i guess
maybe i mean i would put it in the kind of maybe it's correct category actually i don't think it's a very
good method to be honest the math community has its own culture and they're a little bit more rigorous
like they the reviewer tends to read through the whole paper but they won't read arrival the
equations or anything like that often they'll skip steps because it's too hard it takes too long
it's just that it's just that it's just a it's a it's a numbers game right if you've got x researchers
producing a a papers per year let's say one paper per year you've got x new papers per year
uh and they have to be reviewed by experts you have to then send a papers to experts at least every
review every person producing a paper has to review a paper and if they're going to invest energy in
reading it properly they're going to probably have to spend well not the same time as it took to write
the paper but some proportion of their time to to review correctly right and that would be a non-trivial
amount of time let's say it takes i don't know a week to fully review a paper like to the highest
levels of high high high rigor that's okay that's if you've got x people producing eight papers a year
that's x b everyone gets one per year that's not what happens is it so actually people produce uh
more than one paper per year and so you have a
a collection of x experts and they have to review more than one paper per year typically
at least in my inbox i get once every week at least one or two requests to review a paper
i don't know guys does that correlate with your experience you might get less requests but you have
to review right yeah and the week for a paper what do you reckon if you spent every day properly going
through the paper checking everything no no no i mean but it's a paper you know pretty well i don't
know maybe um a weekend plus a couple days extra i don't know something like this so three or four
work days yeah something like that yeah three or four work days so how often do you say yes zero i no
longer accept papers to review uh because that's it's past the the event horizon i cannot actually review
the papers that come into my inbox any longer and also i put into a problem here that i tell every
editor now which is that we can't verify the science has been produced it's no longer possible
we can verify some proportion of it but not really and i'm not the first to say actually this problem has
been known in the math community for decades there are well-known results in the math community by
fields metal awarded people that are wrong everyone knows that they're wrong they tell
each other that these results are wrong and everyone avoids these results and they don't they carefully
don't refer to them in the wrong form but they actually everyone knows that the correct way of
doing it is like this but nobody ever writes this down and it came to the point where one person
guy called the vetsky had concerns about his own proof he did he was no longer convinced that his own proof
of a fields medal award winning result was correct he was just not sure so he was one of the first people
to seriously invest time and energy in automated verification of mathematical results and that's where we're
going today uh he was just so unhappy with the status of his results and whether or not they are true
that he wanted to formalize them and this is the key word that i want to get to today formalization
we've come from consensus based uh verification all the way to the what i consider the highest level
verification which is formalization we'll get to that in a second but i this this story you know has
started to get much more momentum recently uh scientific results are getting harder and harder to verify
because there's more and more of them coming and we're in a crisis where there are more papers
being produced and there are people to review them uh if you want to do a proper review so now we're
down to gut field reviews so you see the paper you go looks okay looks good to me um that's how papers
get reviewed this is just a fact but if you don't believe me just do the numbers just look on the
archive every day there's a whole bunch of papers how many today i don't know a lot um let's see
do this occasionally today there were 94 entries but 41 new submissions so okay it's only 40 today
so if you think that the college of experts in this field of quantum physics how many experts are there
in the world it's probably i don't know you can start working out numbers right just count all the
universities in the world um that's claude while i'm talking um and then we work out how long
or whether or not we're past or built up ahead or behind the event horizon crisis here
so how many um people in quantum physics
in academia and just it doesn't have to be a correct number it just has to be within a couple
of orders of magnitude because the calculation we're going to do won't even matter about the exact numbers
what proportion of those 40 papers do you think is ai generated i don't know anymore actually i think
it's a surprisingly low number that's the thing that's why it's very shocking because i talked to all
my colleagues who were obviously i asked them how are you using ai and it's a shocking number just use
chat gpt just to to talk about ideas with and then they still write the papers here we go that's um
there's a number let's say 30 000 academia quantum people um and then there's a broad broader set which
is yeah kind of maybe um yeah yeah not my kind of work um so let's say if we just took the number of
100 000 active reviewers in the world 100 000 these are the people this is the corpus of people we could
call on to review a paper and so we have 40 per day so we may not be past the event horizon yet but let's
let's let's work it out so we got 40 per day so 40 pages per day times by what is those 250 archive
days in the year roughly speaking so it's 10 000 papers per year now how long did i say did we agree
to do a proper review it was like three or four working days right so let's say three hard working
days it's 30 000 working days need to be invested per year to review all the science that's coming out
at the moment the college of experts is a hundred thousand so yeah it's fine right that's if the
college of experts is a hundred thousand but i fear that the reality is the people that you can call on
for refereeing work is more than in the ten thousand category because a lot of these people here i don't
know where this number of 100 that feels a bit over i mean the total number of members in the dfg is
the dpg is 200 000 something but actually employ people who will do refereeing is closer to about
10 000 would have been my first first number but i'm getting wrong so at least you know we don't seem
to be at the crisis yet but we the problem is we are at the crisis because the actual people who are
qualified enough to referee these papers is much much lower that's the problem these people have
a phd in quantum physics but do you want someone with a phd in statistics to referee your paper on
operator algebras yeah when you get to the the the the the tighter definition then all of a sudden
the college of experts goes from maybe 10 000 to a thousand and then 30 000 starts to be a really
painful number and that's it the pre-ai situation in if you look in neural networks this the study of
neural networks the the numbers are strongly inverted um they have conferences with thousands and
thousands and thousands of thousands of submissions it's just insane the number of papers that are
generated per day in in ai and they can't be refereed anymore and they had this crisis a couple of
years ago so uh and they dropped their standards actually the standard is now every paper has to have
a github repository and the code has to compile i'm joking this is a standard for publication um but
that brings us to our second level of what what it means to verify if you have a program that you can
run then having it run is a pretty good way to check of the correctness of something you know the correct
the program compiles it gives the you give it some inputs it gives you some outputs they match the tests
that you set up that's a fairly high bar for com for for verification and i would put it to you that
that's a fairly high bar it's actually higher in some sense than than referring a paper but that's not
quite where we want to although this is the most effective way to do uh agentic science now is to
get it to write a python program for you to do whatever it is you want to do that's an extremely rapid
way to check something works it's amazing it works really fast you pick a problem in any homework sheet in
any uh lecture in this in the physics institute institute and then ask chat gpt how to solve it
probably it'll write a python program to to test it out this problem you know won't be able to give you
a proof maybe if it's a theoretical result but it'll certainly test some special cases with python programs
you've probably seen this happen right but that's a level of verification that you it's higher level right
we go from college of experts consensus to a program that represents somehow the content runs
but maybe there are edge cases maybe there's examples that can't cover but at least you've
got some signal now that this result is correct or false and this actually works amazingly well for
all kinds of formulas if you guess a formula for something um or even conjecture formula based on some
hints then the first thing you should do is put in the special cases right up to as far as you can go and
if the formula matches for the first 110 cases that you can calculate then you start to think this is
probably correct so that's a level of verification above consensus you go from consensus to writing a
program that kind of does the the happy path the basic examples and then you might want to ascend to
a higher level of verification you know wouldn't it be wonderful to have something that was just correct
and you didn't have to ever have any concerns ever that this result was false as long as the definitions
were correct and there is a way to do it and that's using um uh that is not what i wanted there is a way to
now use uh there is now a way to formalize mathematics in a language which can be computer verified i can show you
one instance of this programming language there are several out there this is probably the the most
actively developed one right now it has the biggest library um we're going to talk about this a bit
today so this is a programming language called lean um how many of you have heard of this
and how many of you played with it wow you belong to a very small community of people
have you ever got the type checker to accept anything i think i used it in years ago yeah a few years ago
okay yeah okay so you've at least heard of it and you've tried it so you you kind of have a sense of what it's like
look it's the most rigorous uh way of representing math that that i think humans have invented it's
as a consequence it's very very boilerplate uh you could spend a long time proving that one plus one equals two
it is possible you can express a proof in this language of the statement and the n plus one is
one plus n and things like that so you start with primitives and then you build up uh lemmas and you
build up a library of true mathematical statements that are formally provably correct and then you can
build on them and build on them and build on them and express mathematics in this language
uh by itself the language is very small it has only a few number of primitives but people have
worked very hard uh and they now have developed a library of formalizations of results in math
and this library started to get good a couple of years ago and by good you've got a large amount of
undergraduate math in there now and not just boring stuff like you know functional analysis is in
there they've got the definition of c star algebra in there they've got uh normal states they've got
uh combinatorics in there geometry they've got it's it's a massive massive massive library of stuff
lots of number theories in there so many many things that you may need to a formal proof of is in this
library you don't have to recreate it and in fact i recommend you don't um and uh and it's being added to all
the time all the time by a small group of really insane people who've made it their life's mission to
turn mathematics into this language you may have even heard of some of them terence towers one of
the kevin buzzard there's a couple of other people kantorovich there's some mathematicians who just
decided this is the most important thing they could be doing right now is formalizing mathematical results
and they're adding to this library and it's it's a huge library and it's useful now so you don't have
to go right back to piano in order to to prove your statement about um operator algebras you can just call
this library and then you have an example a formalized result which is formally proven correct
and the library like it's i'm not going to explain the syntax i'm not going to explain anything about
the language i'm just going to leave it out there that this is a thing that exists
and many many results are in there lemmas about subgroups so anything you might find in an
undergraduate math textbook should at least be uh written in this library not maybe with a missing
proof but it often with a proof so it's pretty extraordinary the amount of stuff that's in there
now why would we talk about that in a in an ai course well because coding agents are trained on the
internet and they know this language they know how to write programs in lean uh and uh how well let's
find out i haven't done this in a while um so what we're going to do is while we're talking i'm going
to ask claude to create a proof of a mathematical statement i'll try and build i hope my mathlib the
mathlib is horrifically large it takes about half an hour to download on it on a hard on an ethernet
connection so i hope i've got a reasonably up-to-date one um so what we'll do is do i have a temp directory
um i'm just gonna ask claude to write me a lean program that proves a mathematical statement that's
kind of hard one that you might be familiar with at the sort of the fourth fifth sixth semester level
i don't know if there are any candidate theorems and proofs that you think are pretty hard but
oh well that'll be interesting what i'll do actually i'll do i'll ask it um
okay i'll tell it that it's in a repo where it has mathlib okay um okay let's get it warmed up so um
so what i'm going to do is this is the kind of hello world of leaves proves that square root
two is irrational which is non-trivial it's actually there's quite a few steps to it
um but what i want to do is get it warmed up so it knows where everything is
because it may already crash out that'll be a bit of a bummer if it doesn't know i already found it
all right okay uh but that's good at least it tested the compiles i i do i wasn't sure if i had it
there but i do okay i'm going to show it you now where did it say it was it said it was under
uh square root two is irrational okay this is what it looks like this is what um this this horrific
programming language looks like now it's very beautiful in many ways um there's this extraordinary
deep connection between type theory category theory and proof theory they're all the same thing
um and lean expresses that so if you want to get it down into that rabbit hole you can and you will
never leave it um okay so this is what uh lean looks like you have theorems go to is irrational
um you have some arguments uh the argument is the number square root two and it's of types blah blah
blah and then you you build up the result in the way that you might uh build it up classically right
so you you might uh assume that uh the number namely square root two is is rational uh so we've got to say
what it is n times n equals two um so your hypothesis you have a hypothesis and then uh you check some cases
and then uh you derive a contradiction it's the kind of standard proof that you might have a square of
two is a russian and it says natural not rational it's natural doesn't it oh that's because it's looking
at the square of it um what have we got here by read write intro the natural number n yeah it's trying
to find a natural yeah okay it's clearing the denominators and working over them um so that's
not a very good theorem what's going on with that one two is not a perfect square okay it's not proving
through two is irrational it's proving that two is not a perfect square uh but that's that's a typical
example of some of some lean code it's if you can read it you can read it if you can't then don't
worry don't try it we're not our objective today isn't to try it but our objective is to see that we
don't have to read it to some extent um here we go we think it's found it compiles cleanly very good
so now let's take on a more difficult task uh you have a candidate i've got one from differential
geometry okay on my current homework sheet yes sorry i'm kind of cheating here um we've got a smooth
manifold m yep please prove for smooth manifold m and on there we have two um line bundles
i'm not sure this may this may not be in the method but let's see i'm curious i don't know actually
uh and uh let's denote them l1 and l2 yep l1 and l2 and we need to show that the tensor product line
bundle or the tensor product bundle l1 tensor l2 i don't have to get it correct yep is isomorphic to l2
tensor l1 so we can they are isomorphic under like reordering all right the tensor product um
is this in mathlib if it's not in mathlib we're kind of cooked uh uh if not uh how far away are we
it might be that they have line bundles they have manifolds and everything they just haven't got this
particular result in there um what is the gap and so i'm curious what it says i actually don't know but
this is the kind of thing where is this is the edge of mathlib right now i'm pretty sure smooth
manifolds in there pretty sure line bundles in there not sure about this result okay it's looking
for it so uh oh yeah it's found topology vector bundles so there is something in mathlib about this
i'm not so good on differential geometry and lean and what might happen is it might a find the theorem
itself in there uh it might say oh no we're very far from it or it might say yeah we need to prove a
couple of lemmas and then we have it and so what but the while it's thinking about it the message
here is i hope becoming clear if you have an llm produce something you've got various ways to to get
confident that the answer is correct you can ask other llms is it correct ask the same question from
other llms take a majority vote ask them to critique each other's work you can get them to write a
program for you to check special cases or you can say formalize this result in this programming language
and all of this can be done in an automated way so where i'm going with this is the the non-human part
they can't do the creative part somehow yet everyone i know tries this out but nobody has
come to me and said oh yes it could come up with good ideas i've never had this yet but
recently some days ago there was some person who played with jgbt and handed it over to someone and
who handed it over to terence town that was a new this is the early result yeah yeah um yeah there is
a lot of and this is a i would say this is not a great signal by the way um that that that press release
because what actually happened is everyone's just throwing chat gpt at erdish problems so you know what
erdish is right mathematician came up with many conjectures and he became famous because he offered
rewards if people could prove these conjectures but the guy was really prolific like he came up with
thousands and thousands of conjectures in fact more conjectures than there are really people interested in
them if i'm brutally honest right lots of erdish problems are not that interesting for other people who
aren't okay it's um it's taken this one serious compiles the file is that summary is it in method no
how far away 500 to one and a half thousand lines of code the work decomposes into four pieces all of
which mirror existing patterns which is good the shortcut line what you can do today for free the fiberwise
argument is the algebraic content go do the results i'm just gonna let it thrash away for this the rest of
the time we're together and so because i want to just leave it there running so you can see the way it
attacks these problems oh erdish problems oh erdish problems yeah um and so what people have just
done is they've done the natural thing is oh i've got a whole list of problems that someone said were
important i'll throw an llm at it and since there are more problems than mathematicians interested in
them there's lots of problems that have kind of not been explored even by simple methods that have
been developed in the past 50 years and yeah you're going to get a hit every so often i'll be honest
without about to go a fully general intensive product is 500 lines yeah you said that already don't
complain um what come on um it's complaining about the the the far beyond what's prudent in one session
um if you don't finish um we can pick up in another session so uh it's this is a the late the
latest clawed model actually complains a lot about things being added too hard and there's a good
reason for doing this actually because the previous call model was pretty aggressive uh it would just
take on any problem no matter how hard and then go for it and you know sometimes it kind of
overestimated its abilities and led to kind of nonsense uh and so they've obviously sort of trained
the next model to be a bit more cautious uh and so it always does this thing now where it's like oh
this may be a bit too much so uh this is going to happen a lot now there's thousands of these urge
problems uh people are just going to throw chat gpt at it because it costs them nothing and then
eventually you're going to get a hit and this in my opinion is the worst possible outcome because
because it still relies on experts to evaluate the results and that means it's sucking the that very
little energy that experts have away from good science to now deal with this flood of ai slop it's
a very different kind of slop but it's yeah it's and the thing is people will create these lean proofs
of these others problems that's how they will present them like that and it's a good thing but still lean
proofs need reading uh why because the definitions could be wrong so that's the failure mode of formalization
i've seen it happen many times by the way in a formalization in lean you formalize it say
woohoo i've done it uh and then you look and then you've got one of the definitions wrong
so it said you know a smooth manifold is a manifold where the functions are twice differentiable
and you're like what no this is not a smooth manifold you know that that's the kind of
error that can happen and so as if you get the definition wrong you can prove things right
and so humans still need to read the definitions so uh all of the inline definitions or just some at
the beginning uh any definition is subject to failure yeah you can introduce um errors in any
definition because it's a definition right you can't argue with it the consequences fine you don't have
to read those you know that's that's that's the way you should operate actually so what it's trying to do
now it's going to build up the skeleton of a proof and then instead of giving you the proof itself
it replaces the proof with something called sorry and sorry in the lean language means proof not there
but it type checks still so it's it's an acceptable proof but it's not a proof
it's a placeholder and that way you can build together very powerful proofs like with lots and
lots of statements without having the proofs there yet and so lots of theorems of theorems they're well
known um you can trust them it's just that you haven't formalized the proof and you want to see
where it goes so sorry allows you to do that you don't trust it it's not a proof but it's it allows
you to build up bigger bigger proofs build the construction so that's what it's doing now so it's
it's going to do that for the probably the next whatever hour whatever we let it do um and you can do
that and i've tried this a lot in the past months i take results and i build math uh lean proofs with
claude for various things uh and and if you give it enough time it will do all those hundreds of lines
that it complains about um and it appears to be correct so how much can you produce with claude
claude in a weekend you can produce about 80 pages of latex with lean proofs subject area
functional analysis so operator algeism that's realistic that's an actual number that i can
give you as a data point uh it can do quantum computing stuff in lean it it can do yeah i haven't
found anything it can't do but you have to have the idea first like it you have to have the proof
assembled if you have no proof you know if you just write down that green manzilla hypothesis or
something it'll just it'll thrash around have no idea how to get a proof you have to have you have
to kind of have the proof already how long does it take you to so you said you have to verify that
the definitions are correct right how long does it take you to verify that like for an 80 page long
honestly uh uh an infinite time i haven't really checked the definitions uh because there's another
way so it's not proof proof right because the definitions could be wrong but there's this thing
that if you get definitions wrong and you derive consequences then you get contradictions very
quickly this is this is some there's some kind of robust structure in math that if you if you get
the definitions wrong then pretty soon somewhere down the line you'll derive a consequence that somehow
gets crazier and crazier and crazier like the mistakes get amplified so i there are subtle bugs that could
be there yeah there are subtle bugs that could be in the proof absolutely uh and i haven't read all
the definitions but uh because there were no kind of crazy contradictions i'm fairly confident if it
mattered enough to me i would read the definitions though does lean check that definitions are like
consistent within other definitions uh not directly so the definition can exist in lean code and contradict
literally contradict another definition it can literally contradict another definition and you
wouldn't know to begin with like it's only when you start deriving consequences that all of a sudden
you start deriving results that seem weirder and weirder and then at some point they'll be
hopefully a hard contradiction so this is the kind of this is the last stuff i can share with you that
called these coding agents are really actually really good at this lean code like it complains
that 500 is too much for it's not yeah i think i actually think it can do this in one session
i've seen it do this kind of thing and what it's doing is it does this gradual iteration process where
it fills it out with these sorries and then it'll attempt to prove and it'll fail and it'll attempt to
prove and it'll fail and it gets the feedback is fast so it sees ah that didn't work i'll try this
and so the proof quickly accelerates um towards correctness i i know some lean experts and they
tell me that the code that it generates is ugly i can't judge i'm not an expert but
but is truth beautiful so uh that's more or less the last amount of stuff i could share with you beyond
all the weird crazy that i collected over the past months um in the last seminar we discussed what i
think is a vision which is coordinated action to do science uh today we discuss what is truth
effectively or verification like how can you verify something and give a signal back to an agent and
we discuss these various layers and lean is kind of like this highest level but there's still we need
to check the definitions isn't you can get other agents to check the definitions but do you trust
that yeah at some point the human has to look at it and now i would propose that for the rest of the
series we start with some kind of mini project and see where we can go with that
yep wouldn't it be easier to state the final theorem in lean code and then just ask it to fill out the
lemmata to prove it uh you can try that because then you wouldn't need to check definitions because
you put in the necessary open the theorem itself will refer to objects right yeah but those might
be in the standard library and if they're in the standard library you're golden yeah it's only when
there's something that you need that isn't in the standard library then you're kind of in this
so i misstated actually so the definitions that i'm talking about are ones that aren't in the standard
library already in this case it doesn't know what a tensor product is or what's the problem it does
it's just that there's so many versions of tensor product in the in the mathlib it's it doesn't know
which level of abstraction to rise to so it has category theory it's actually mathlib is an excellent
category theory coverage because proof theory is category theory so it's actually the first thing
that got done and they're you know tensor products are a concept in category theory but are they the
same tensor product as the one you want you have to get yourself into the right category that's what's
going on here what you have no so what three uh automatically yields what's left assemble the
coast cycle into that blah blah connect to the literal file so the construction decision is a real
bundle level proof the gaps are packaging not new math so apparently it's it's proved it
but using mathlib it's relying on definitions and lemmas already in mathlib and it may not be the
proof you want it to be right because what it might do is it might take the most general category theory
statement and specialize it down to what you have and that's probably not what's going to get you
the grade on the assignment no you know if you go in there saying you know let let c be a fibered
category you know um you can try i mean it's don't think you're going to get the grade you want um
um so but i i'm now suspecting it's probably correct because it's just seems to have used mathlib stuff
so that that was pretty quick right now imagine that you're doing research on a problem and you're
like i don't know is this conjecture correct i have an idea here's the idea of the proof here's the
theorem is it a mathlib no it's not a mathlib um what's missing oh 50 lines of code go on claude just try
it out so now when the llm spits out the answer you are like 99 sure right definitions are in mathlib
the lean code is there maybe it introduced the definition you go to check
and you didn't have to do that at all you automated that so even though there was the content it
produces is random noisy has error rates you can increase that error rate to almost zero so that's
i've done this and it does work in fact the slow thing now is me i just don't generate ideas quicker
it sounds funny but it's actually sort of true so you use it for real research problems you had and
proved them the problem is what's gonna what happens next so you have an idea and 99 of the time is
wrong or at least my success rate with ideas is low uh so good this is the kind of tool but it spins
its wheels when it's wrong like it clawed lean it doesn't just come out and say something's wrong
it'll just say i don't know how to prove this and so you've gotten where have you gotten right what
what signal have you gained from this a bit maybe you kind of know it's not tributally correct
can you say find a contradiction you can do that and that works yeah
so you can find contradictions pretty easily if they're to be found it often finds them which is
just by writing a python program actually that's the quickest way that finds most of them and but
if it's true and you don't know the proof it'll spin its wheels forever if it's true and you know
the proof but you can't be bothered with the details that's the power that's the accelerator right
there because then you can say the proof is going to be this this and this can make it formal
and then it will really go uh if it's untrue um but the the counter example is hard to find
yeah you're lost so yeah it's it's an accelerator but in certain ways and it can't stack together ideas
so you you know a big interesting proof is full of different ideas that are drawn together in a
complex web and then they come together to imply the final statement it's it's use case because of the
context windows even with a million tokens we used for that proof we used a hundred thousand tokens for that
proof um so it can hold about 10 of those in its context to give you a sense of and then but its
inference power is going down with the context so realistically you can hold about three of these
in its context before the quality goes down which is interesting right you know if you can break
your task down into vector bundle tensor product level things and you need implications of three or four
at a time then yeah i can hold that in context so what i want from you now is ideas i just told you
i can't come up with ideas quick enough um but one more question yeah and if you're reading if you
if you're getting the output and it's the lean document yes do you read the actual document or i don't like
to but yeah i can okay to do because then it's giving you a proof but you don't know the proof yet right
exactly yeah it's a black box okay you know it's true but it's a black box so then before you
before you publish a paper about it to be honest i haven't published a single paper since i got into
the ai things yeah so we come to an interesting point yeah so but claude writes this code without
like running it in lean so you still know you have to run it it's been running it in lean the whole time
okay yeah and it what it showed you was lean programs running it erred it said oh it has an
error i got to change it it was doing it over and over and over in the loop actually yep and it has
these handoff files there yes um that's a standard sort of llm thing a handoff is a document that
an agent will write so the next agent that you bring to the project can read this short summary
and it knows what to do the question and i'll show you what a handoff looks like uh what was
done in this session it looks like this i didn't ask for it but it it writes things like this you know
i did this i did this and it tells the next action what to do and so and then it draws these little
pictures and it's all very satisfying you know that it does it uh you can see the agents they come
into existence they do their work and then and then they hand off the work and they have a picture for
the next agent of what the work is meant to be and you can you know you have like 10 agents in a day
picking up one after the other the work that's so yeah i think the the effective way we have some
priorities in the center one is this environmental cost thing um as i said i think clara was going to
pick up that in i think i signed up for that oh did you sign up for that yeah okay uh because there's
lots of information being leaked about the frontier models like how many weights they have um how much
had some hard time finding infos about for example opos for certain i saw on hacker news there was a
leak on the number of weights there's a study people like ai researchers try and infer this information
from from the from claude or from chat gpt they have all these tricks and they've estimated claude has
1.1 trillion weights and chat gpt 5.4 has about 1.4 trillion so it's the information is being exposed
through various ways so that's like a multiple of the open source models which are yes 32 or something
yeah they're in the billions although the first trillion weight models have been released haven't
they recently recently i'm not sure that that means that the online ones are like 100 times larger than
yes the downloadable ones yeah how good the measure is this i don't know okay but uh
i don't know is the quick answer there's something different intrinsically different between a trillion
weight model and a hundred thousand weight model uh sorry 100 right there's something just really
the the behavior of opus is just different to that of sonnet i can't explain it except through lots
of experience it seems to have an understanding where other models don't yeah so somehow like
if you have one billion models can we assume that they are roughly on the same level or more
i mean they can be a little bit different but they tend to be comparable because you you
given the number of make weights that you have you optimize these certain benchmarks that everyone
tries to gain um sweet bench there's all these like these targets that they optimize when they're
training these models and everyone's aiming at the same plots so if you've got a billion weights to
optimize then you'll optimize it for those plots and therefore it'll perform roughly comparably to every
other billion weight model so then what's the reason that they don't upscale it to 100 trillion or so
well now you just ask the important question um that there is no reason except compute
it turns out that if you go to uh 10 trillion that's more compute than there is in the world
and 100 trillion is more than we can ever build um we're getting into those kinds of numbers now
so how does it fail badly
yeah i mean the training costs alone just get go up much more than the number of weights
so uh we if you believe the ceos of these companies then they're talking about having
bought all the data centers in the world for the next models and i i think it's roughly believable um
they've hired all the compute in the world for the training of the next models and they're all playing
a game right the game is what happens if i extrapolate this line because people have put that there's
this famous inter line in yeah so you're talking about money cost i think uh so i signed up for
environmental cost yeah yeah that's a different cost yeah although it's probably correlated yeah
uh yeah if you put all the models on this curve maybe i can find it um then you can see just
by extrapolating compute you're going somewhere pretty amazing um what is the it's the karpati curve i
think karpati curve llms maybe it's this one well and wait so they there's there's a scaling law that
people started to notice there is a scaling law that i wanted to show you that convinced everyone to invest
in compute and people started putting llms it was gpt one two three on this this law
and they saw that if they just extrapolated this with a line because why wouldn't you extrapolate
with a line um then if you could invest uh in like to 10 trillion to 100 trillion weight models you
would reach some something you would pass some threshold and i can't tell you anything more
than these vibes but that's what people saw this curve and then they're like oh
shit all we need to do now is invest money no new ideas are needed
and so that's why everyone went nuts in silicon valley they all realized that just by putting money
into the problem they could scale their way up to something called agi which no one knows
can you scroll one centimeter up like here yeah i know that the upper half of the image
oh because you can't see it i imagine i was just thinking about this curve because it makes me very
skeptical that this is the right scaling law for these data points they they don't have many data points in
the in the top range and then they just cut it off yeah but this is how it works in this game that was
very scummy in my opinion yeah this is people do this all the time you don't have to believe it i would
encourage you to be skeptical because in my or as far as i have read um small models with the same number
of parameters got better mostly because the training data got better um and because that's true you just
had more time to train since the inception of large language models if you keep on training and fine
tuning then of course your model gets better even if the parameter count doesn't change and also the
parameter count doesn't tell you anything about the architecture of the model these are all true
statements so you can't really say oh okay every three billion parameter models performs bad in the same
way i think just keeping training isn't making it necessarily better because you can do overfitting
that's true but if you have the training data to keep training then that's okay because fine tuning
means you add training data and uh keep on training on that new data which was in the original set so
but one would imagine that at some point you've extracted all the gains you can out of your parameters
yeah your weights i mean of course there's a limit to how good you can fit anything with n parameters
yeah uh and so i'm expressing you so i can't answer the questions with any concrete answers but only
with the general feelings that are in the community and the general feelings are more parameters equals
better at the moment um and is it's it's easier not cheaper to say it's easier to throw more parameters
at the problem than it is to throw more computers at a smaller problem at a smaller model although i have
to say that the parameters i could run on my computers have been constant for the last couple of yeah years
and now the the models are much better than they were before so there is evolution happening without
increasing parameter size yeah i mean you say that for sure yeah that is definitely happening you're
right i'm before it's just much much better than i don't know lama 2 yes this is legitimately they are
comparatively in the same the same order of magnitude of parameters so um i don't i don't know uh whether
or not we could keep pushing it it would be kind of cool if you could take i mean the ai researchers
i'm talking to actually believes that you can get a lot more out of the out of these smaller models and
than what is already there because people still aren't really trying hard it might be that they
and there's this mixture of experts model that you've actually experienced yourselves where
problems get pre-routed to smaller models that's when they talked about active 2 billion or something
like that or active what's actually happening is there's a little architecturally the problem gets
pre-sorted to a smaller transformer which you can operate actively and then get your answer back out
and there's a lot of active deep seekers the ones who uh pioneered this to make it practical
and their performance can be pretty close to to bigger uh bigger models and the model the
transformer architecture itself hasn't really been optimized people just it's the first thing that
works and that they can scale and parallelize so people are just way hard like that but it could be
that you could look at neural networks that aren't just a classic neural network where you multiply
in floating point numbers but multiply binary numbers these exist and they're harder to train and they should have
theoretically the same capability and people are looking into these questions but the priority
the incentive isn't there at the moment and that brings us back to the paper we yeah we read because
we already we also know that Moore's law might not continue as it did so i don't know if the statement
from the from the essay remains true yeah i saw Moore's law die mostly was more about speed right because
of course we can still scale money and buy more compute but that's it still makes research into
the smaller models useful because ordinary people like us can run them without access to
huge amounts of compute in the cloud i think this is i mean this is for me a key priority imagine you
could run a model that's of jama but on your phone theoretically you can because neural networks are
binary uh operations you know these things called perceptrons they take in a binary and they output a
binary the thing you do in the middle is you you do some floating point multiplications you can replace
every neural network with a pure binary uh network which is a hundred times more efficient to evaluate
the problem is is we don't know how to efficiently take one of these floating point neural networks to
one of these binary neural networks there's no efficient way of doing that yet it's possible it
exists but the problem you have to solve is very very hard it's an optimization problem so that there
there is a potential that we could have sonnet gemma level stuff on on on phones locally run
but that you have to solve an optimization problem that's so hard that nobody's ever managed it
i think the two billion gemma four version is targeted at phones at least at least yeah i mean
it can if a chat things are okay right if you're not doing types then maybe
maybe maybe it's you in this case spits out perfectly fine latex when you want types
even types was okayish yeah but in the large version the smaller version yeah okay no chance
so i'm as i said i'm interested in ideas right so what we need a plan we need to go somewhere so now
we could just come every week and talk about cool we've seen or not right that's one thing
or you could start to bring your agendas to the table like why are you even here and we can work
on your agenda like i've got my agenda whatever and that depends on you thinking about what you want
and i gave you this this exercise last week come up with a problem that you'd be impressed by you
had some very interesting answers um i don't propose that we investigate any of those
um well i looked into the signal one though and um you could do it turns out but then you'd have to
port you'd have to have your own port of the signal client that every time it updates you have
to re re-implement it and then no one else would have it so you would be able to see latex
in your signal but no one else would see it in theirs i was very sad by this but well what about
this is this is where we are um so we could do that but i think the interesting thing is like
you're the generation coming to inherit this stuff i'm the older generation i'm not the right
generation here to ask these questions any longer what is the world you want to create right this is
the question that i want you to start thinking about and then what other steps that can get you there and
the world you want to create is probably a an amazing dream that we won't ever reach in one's
lifetimes but going in the right direction can create interesting things so there's various ways to
do this we could come up with a mini project that people work on we could define a larger goal and
then make steps along the way we could uh uh investigate just a random 10 side projects and
see what comes out of that you don't have to answer me now this is not the point the point is by next
week please think about what is it what's the world that you want to create what is it that you
want to actually do and if you're willing to share it you know you might be able to convince other
people that help you in that way and then this seminar is if it's in a scientific direction and
i kind of hope that it is then you can use the seminar as a forum to start exchanging knowledge
or get that work done i don't have anything else prepared this is the end of my content for the
seminar so if you want something to happen next week you better start coming with your own ideas yep
yeah it's not quite the direction you want to go in but uh any direction is better than no direction
i i would like to be convinced that agi is not a threat you'd like to be convinced agi is not a threat
uh so like i think one of your blogs you have this argument where you say thermodynamics and such
oh that one um yeah yeah so i i think i would be happy if i can go out of this seminar and say oh
yeah that's not that right i mean maybe that is the right thing to focus on um like i'm convinced
so no i'm not convinced about agi uh i can't prove anything about agi because that's not a well-defined
term but yeah so like singularity yeah i don't believe in these singularity uh arguments this idea of
recursive self-improvement because every time you make that uh concrete as an optimization problem
you are effectively saying i can solve for global optima you know landscape with many local optima
so if you know what those words mean then you already see the seed of the answer right if you if
there is something you can optimize and it's a very bumpy optimal uh landscape you're going to get
stuck in local minima the idea of recursive self-improvement is the man it's a magical spell
that takes you out of a local minima to a better local minima or you're into a global minima so this
is the and once you identify that that's the magic spell that people are talking about then you ask what
is the cost of getting from a local minima to another local minima in an optimization landscape and then
you start to write down numbers and you start to write down that you have to write down every parameter
that you've tried in order to to verify that one local minima is better than another and then we can
talk about dimension there is an argument it takes 10 deductive steps i would say uh to prove that we
run out of memory before we run out of before we get anywhere close to this magical thing is this
somehow published somewhere no but it's you can string it together from a bunch of moments it's
uh and the thing is i'll convince maybe you maybe two or three people in this room and then other
people will be like no no i don't believe you uh you didn't think about this and then we'll add in
that factor have a new argument and then no i've seen these narratives go along before in various fields
of scientific endeavor uh just disproving one version of the statement just encourages people to come up
with new with new versions of the statement and that carries the discussion away from where it should
be so we can formalize it and you know it's this still might be the right place to do this but yeah
and so like from your personal view it's something that it's it it's a concern for you and maybe that
i should listen to that and you know as a signal but um actually maybe the right time to ask the
question you are all what level are you now masters bachelors so i mean some of you are in all of them
are in the same semester but me i'm one semester high okay right so you've all kind of done your
bachelor projects right so you've done your bachelor and you're now thinking about masters or doing
masters right and then you're all thinking about doing something after masters because this might be
the right moment to have this discussion right what is your your direct general directions you're in
the theoretical physics institute all of you i think i've seen all of you right yeah not yeah i'm uh
might go into energy workshop okay well maybe yeah that's maybe it's a good place to go
and phds are a thought in your heads or not maybe if you go to energy you still do a phd there you know
um why am i asking this because you're probably thinking about academic things then researching
things right you know what what do you want to create then something in the physics domain so the
problem i find interesting at the moment is uh really understanding that's theorem and which version
of it is true but that's a problem about understanding not about having a proof that's but that's an
interesting take home here really understanding maybe because if we collect questions like this
we might see that we can use ai tools to help in in the more abstract task of really understanding it
right now but so i had uh quantum physics with mr werner four years ago and since then i tried to really get
to the ground of it but and have various versions of it but i never managed to really say okay yeah
that's true and this version is the one that's correct interesting so but you would it but you would
know the moment you really understand would you i hope no but you you must have a sense like you
know i would really understand it if i really understood so there there's a thing that uh
philosophers say yeah okay we are clearly non-local and there's nothing about classicality here and
verna says no those are two different assumptions yes and i want to get to a point where i can say okay
those argument is correct and i believe okay those party this party okay that's a that's a big goal
i think it's achievable um and maybe ai tools can help you yeah we've been talking about this a bit
the difference between you and us yes because we our main goal is to learn stuff and your goal
is to teach and maybe to publish so you already have an idea of something you want to you want to
prove you want to show and then you can use ai to formalize that for you and for us it's it's like it's
a little more a little bit more different because our main goal is to understand and as you've already
said we cannot trust ai to to teach us something so that's a bit of a problem right yeah so when we
before talked about this chess a chess computer black box so are there people that are interested
to understand what this like forces do to like try to find new ways to yeah it's called explainable ai
it's um it's a field of research but i i think um i can come back to that in a second but you both
actually asked a similar question i think yeah i think you just asked the question which is it seems
that i'm about teaching and you're about understanding yeah exactly but actually what you didn't notice is
that got flipped uh i'm now far more interested in understanding than i am in teaching um because
i suddenly realized i can understand a lot more you when you become a domain expert the world the walls
close in i don't know how to explain this you get better and better at a certain sub area but at the
expense of operational competency in other areas does that make sense yeah sure yeah um so i may know
very very very very much about tensor networks but i don't even know very much about multicolor
methods which are literally an adjacent area of studying and the walls close in you spend more
energy on getting better at your domain and less energy on even just the neighboring domain and i know
little to nothing about nuclear physics like you probably know more nuclear physics than i do
maybe maybe not but it's it's you pick something else and you will know something more than me
the walls close in as a domain expert uh and with ai i've suddenly realized you can reach operational
competency in far more many areas very rapidly so you can develop a breadth of understanding instead of
a depth of understanding so you don't understand nuclear physics okay learn nuclear physics you don't
trust necessarily the output of an llm but you start to learn how to verify the output
and now all of a sudden you do know about nuclear physics because it teaches you the basic models
in the language that you know and that you can verify with little demonstration the uh examples
tailored to the way you think
of the way you think but when i asked gemma for to explain me what a hilbert space is or to define it
it it was correct but it was slightly off so yeah it took some properties split them in half combined
others and so i think that's it's not outputting the uh it in a way we should think about it and maybe
that i think that's a model problem rather than yeah okay than a llm problem okay because i think if
you had the experience if you ask opus 4.7 you would get a different experience
in opus 4.5 so this is a problem you know the good answers come only when you pay for them
and i don't know a solution to this problem but i thought hilbert space is maybe enough on the bottom
level that it could do that even if it can't define me for normal algebra right yeah but it was kind
of bad it's disappointing that you know i would have hoped for just a bit better yeah to be honest
but as i said i hope we can start with our 3090 gpu that you can access and then you can start with
maybe some pretty good models and then the server we can finally get running and then you get some
really decent models and then at some point well maybe we get credits from one of the labs and then
let us use them so i would claim that uh teaching that understanding is the goal yes actually i i have
that as a shared goal i mean we're not yet publishers right or not even like researchers
at least from from my understanding so there's not really like something i want i want to investigate
right but you're curious about things right yeah sure but i don't know how you think about this but like
for me currently i'm i'm attending lectures i'm i'm trying to follow the stuff that the professor says
yes i'm trying to to understand it so that's currently my main goal again in a couple of years
maybe i do my phd and then i'm a researcher yeah so i put it to you that i don't know much more than
you in some domains already and that that that you don't need to know much more to start stringing
things together it's a new idea i think the idea is you get breadth of understanding instead of depth
of understanding and that there's this used to be too expensive it used to be too expensive to get
breadth of understanding because you'd have to do a bachelor in in in nuclear physics and sorry a master's
thesis in nuclear physics and master's thesis in quantum optics you know so you have to do 10
master's theses in order to get this breadth of understanding but now you can you can get there
very much quicker so that's some yep would you say has changed so like the ability to ask yes yeah
because if you you know what stops you from understanding a thing when you're sitting in the
lectures just that yeah but also like this is this is impedance mismatch right so the lecturer is
saying something on the board and you're writing it down and it's building up and and your understanding
builds in a non-linear fashion it doesn't really build linearly it's this network effect thing and then
there's these things you get stuck on really quickly like what why is this why do they keep
defining this thing and i don't understand why they're defining this thing and your brain is losing
cycles just with these these questions in every in every lecture like why is it that they're going
on with this letter a i don't understand there's a but i'll write it down anyway and then so you know
at the end of the lecture you have three four five i don't know how many things you've collected
where you're you're spinning you're spinning on this and then eventually you you'll land them and
you'll be like oh okay i see now why why they but if you could ask a question for every one of
those things spinning in your head straight away and say why is it that people define that give me an
answer give me a picture give me a animation give me a you know stop the spinning plates in your head
by immediately asking for feedback then you with a bit of practice you can learn this much much faster
because you'll think the things that keep you slow you down don't slow other people down and vice versa
and a linear medium like video is a linear or a lecture like you can ask a question in a lecture
right and occasionally you do but you don't right you don't ask all your questions because you wouldn't
because then you'd be the annoying person who's stopping the lecture from working right but if you had
if you had a personal assistant who will answer every question for you
as soon as you have them and give you a little illustration or an animation or an interactive demo
then it stops those wheels there's plates spinning in your head and then you can you can learn much
faster it's the the interactive proof
yes and you can ask any question you don't have to be embarrassed and you won't disturb anyone else
i do i actually do um because there's stuff that these uh humans are still better interacting with
humans i think even despite what i just said but we'll see maybe more do you keep this information
as long as if you had it earned in a harder way earned it in a harder way i think so like i think i
understand scattering theory much better now yeah because i have these little demos that i made where
like wave packets come onto the onto the uh the atom and they scatter off and i can actually see the
detectives five because a textbook doesn't give you that a blackboard doesn't give you that an animation
from cern doesn't give you that but the thing that i was missing was connecting the packet coming
in scattering off the nucleus versus this p s wave expansion from taylor's book on scattering theory
and for me i now understand it far better than the hard way
how do you even visualize uh so this is a bit tangential but no i think this is the good way
yeah this is a good direction so how do you even visualize a red packet that's an interesting
question right what would be satisfying for you i actually came up with an answer for this
that satisfied me we can plug the the modulus and color in the face yeah but that's still just pure
state so why is it just pure states well the phase is right maybe um but do you need the phase
information maybe you can get information just from the probability distribution maybe that's enough
to help you understand something so i i did a thing right i'm going to show you because i was
this blew my mind i didn't think this was possible and then it was um i what i think is awesome are
these 3d movies that you see on these cosmology channels on youtube right they show you this or that
phenomena and you can like see the black holes merge or whatever and i was wondering couldn't we just
visualize quantum processes at the microscopics level in three dimensions like what's stopping
us right shouldn't we just shouldn't this be possible now like isn't this software to do 3d
animations and the answer is of course there's software to do 3d animations um so you make it
yourself you just ask claude to write you a 3d visualizer and it doesn't take that long
um you can get a 3d visualization happening in about an afternoon with claude so what do i do here this
is the picture i always wanted to have in um in teaching the hydrogen atom you have the hydrogen atom
the electron is in a p orbital it's in a magnetic field it's spinning around in the magnetic field
and then it's spontaneously emitting into the electromagnetic background field
uh so it collapses down to the 1s state uh and um it's physically correct so this is not the
i'm plotting here the electron density uh not the phase the phase information i can't plot this way
but the actual electron density cloud in three dimensions uh and it's physically correct and it's
using a density matrix not some stupid pure state garbage uh and you think it up and then it becomes
possible that's the kind of thing that where i think you can supercharge your understanding like
this i've written down these orbitals and on blackboards for years and like no it's the moment
right you're in the quantum theory lecture you know laguerre polynomials exponentials you've lost you
don't understand anything but you can visualize it so yeah okay but this image is on wikipedia
is it uh not spinning but uh exactly i looked for this image yeah uh i don't didn't find it anywhere
but it doesn't stop with that one i can now generate any image i want like hydrogen okay what happens if
i have a helium you know how does the the electron bounce between the nuclei you know this is this is
these questions i could just ask and it's a trivial corollary now of the code there's nothing stopping and
then i've used this to to generate um scattering movies i also wanted to render the what the black
hole looks like when you get up close to it but with the physically correct permissive thermal gas
around it rather than the stupid fake stuff things so you if you can think of the question then all of
a sudden you should ask her right and that's how you can supercharge your understanding is if you can see
it you can touch it you can feel it you can ask questions you can get feedback all the things you
can't get in a lecture and that gives you the breadth of understanding that you don't otherwise get
i don't know about depth i mean depth is still kind of hard work but talking about breadth here so yeah
my homework for you is kind of simple which is start asking yourself what your goal is what you want
and if your goal is understanding bell's theorem then we should start wondering how can we visualize
learn understand that in a way that accelerates your understanding and if your goal is to understand
this or that is fine that's a goal because probably if your goal is to understand something
and you'll build stuff to get you there and that stuff that you build will be interesting for someone
else that's the that's what i think unlocks the kind of interesting questions and by the way if you
want to know what a neutron star looks like i also wanted i really really annoyed me that i didn't i
want to visualize a real neutron star so i can't stop it at the right moment but there is one of
these frames is the the optical emission spectra of our nearest neutron star with the relativistic
corrections and the gas there's a gas there's an atmosphere around neutron stars of hydrogen atoms
and these hydrogen atoms in such a ginormous magnetic field that their wave functions are squished
and so they don't behave like normal hydrogen atoms and so they have a different emission
but that's a different frequency so yeah good okay so uh yeah is it clear what the homework is come
back with something you want to do and then if you want to start preparing some initial research in
the environmental costs elements that this discussion can go on many times good so it shouldn't be a full
seminar talk but yeah okay look it's better if it's like 10 minutes yeah if you just say i investigated
this model and found that it cost that much but to train it or whatever i don't know it starts a
discussion right i don't want the full answer so i signed you're registered now is that right uh i will do that
okay